(typing)
- Hey, Lyle!
What are you doing up there?
- This world is just too much.
- Jupiter's way bigger.
- Huh?
- My favorite's planet
Melmac, it's where ALF's from.
- I'm going to end it, Elmer.
- Are you talking about
our FarmVille co-op?
Who's gonna take care of
Sunflower Meadows with me?
- Not FarmVille, me.
I'm going to end me.
Are you even listening?
- My favorite episode
was when ALF met Elvis.
No cat's safe around ALF.
- Shoulda just done
this in the tub.
♪ Oh, we got it made
♪ Yeah, nothing's
gonna get us down
♪ Everything's perfect
♪ 'Cause baby we got it made
- Come on, Lyle.
You've got tons of reasons
not to kill yourself.
Like your hair looked really
great a couple days ago
and you like drinking water,
can't do that if you're dead.
And
I mentioned the
hair thing, right?
- Lyle, I dunno if you're
a Christian or not,
but let me put this delicately.
If you kill yourself, you
goin' to motherfuckin' hell.
- That's very delicate, Anita.
- Hell is hot and shit!
They gonna turn your butt
hole into fresh direct.
- He's Buddhist.
- That big boobied White
Castle Montel Williams?
Jesus could beat his ass, nigga.
He could take out any nigga.
- Not RoboCop.
- Bullshit!
That motherfucker looks like
an air conditioner's dick.
- At that time in history,
Jesus could not properly
train to combat a
cybernetic police officer--
- I'm sick of this shit!
First off, we all know that
RoboCop could kick Jesus' ass.
Second off, you're gonna
kill yourself, Lyle?
You're gonna end it?
Well, guess what, Lyle,
we're all miserable,
but we come here every
day and do our job
and do you know why that is?
- No, not really.
- Well, it's because...
Wait, we have reasons
to live, right?
- Of course we do.
We...
- Switching gears, Lyle,
if you don't kill yourself,
you can break any
piece of art you want.
- I like the art.
- Don't be a hero!
Doesn't this stuff piss you off?
(clay shattering)
This one's even more retarded!
It's got a lady holding an
umbrella but the sun's shining!
Am I not gettin' somethin' here?
You're not smarter than me!
(clay shattering)
For the sake of your
friends, your family,
the Kennedys, Martin
Luther King, the troops,
Brittany Murphy, the
guy Radio was based on,
don't kill yourself!
- Lyle, I genuinely
don't wanna see you hurt.
- Really?
- Really.
You're a nice guy.
There's no reason for any
of us to kill ourselves.
(clay shattering)
There's no reason for most
of us to kill ourselves.
- Okay, okay, I won't jump.
(fan clunks on)
Ahh!
Ghost!
(screaming)
- Lyle!
(thud)
(Lyle grunting)
- Still alive.
- Well, I'm glad
everything's back to normal.
(Lyle gagging)
(Elmer chuckling)
- Same old Lyle.
- I don't even know what
you're going to do about this.
- Taxi!
(tires screech)
- [Taxi Driver] Hey!
- [Richie] Fuck you!
♪ We got it made
♪ Yeah, nothing's
gonna get us down
♪ Everything's perfect